you've also made a lot of videos uh
about guns in America as well both of
you right yeah yeah you did the one
where you strapped an automatic gun to
one of those dogs that was the most
terrifying video I've ever seen as you
did the video in the same Ranch kind of
talking about guns yeah why people are
obsessed with guns yeah
um okay there's a lot to unpack yeah
where do we start wait okay I'm curious
how the [__] did you get one of those
dogs how did you convince someone to let
you have a dog it was pretty funny
because it was um one of the Boston
Dynamics this was like a rip-off thing
yeah it's still a good dog
versions of that dock that seems like
such a specialized Town yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy to think China probably saw
it and was like we can do that for
cheaper as well but we can do it for
cheaper
um but yeah it was funny because I hit
up the company which is I'm gonna say
their name because I find it funny to
piss them off uh uni tree
I was like oh can I do this I want to
put a gun on it and they're just like
first they were interested and then when
they heard the idea just no response
yeah so I tried contacting different
people no I wanted to but I found a man
who wanted to remain anonymous I didn't
think he just named a random name
random man and people are so pissed off
was it Anonymous but you named him
um but yeah and then this guy really
liked the idea and really wanted to know
what would happen and he happened to be
in the same place no as uh in Texas as
the guy that had the guns was like this
is perfect yeah um so yeah we got in
contact with him got the uh the dog and
then went to uh Brandon herrera's Place
who's a big gun YouTuber I've never
heard of this guy until yeah yeah
um and then you know put a machine gun
on the dog and it was terrifying there
was no it was a bad video like that oh
yeah that is so that you asked the most
dangerous thing that is the most the
scariest thing we're controlling the dog
here like a little it was the GoPro app
and the worst thing was that I was like
okay safety we're behind a mound so if
the dog flips over yeah it'll be safe
but the GoPro lost signal behind the
mound so I had to like stick my head up
with the GoPro looking and then when I
saw it shoot it would have to dodge but
obviously you can't dodge a bullet
turned towards me would have been too is
like the dog was so unstable with like a
fully automatic weapon on top of it so
like any time it would burst fire the
dog would just like flip around and lift
up it would go just run back holy [__]
yeah
like how did you go about testing that
in a safe environment yeah we started
with like one bullet in the in the in
the magazine single shot
um but still it's really scary just
really scary and that's like my videos
are scary but then being around
something that's well designed to kill
people yeah and then mucking around with
that is just like something else like
yeah so why well I thought it would be
like propose an idea to the Americans
who seem very like willing to do
anything else besides like gun controls
like let's do an American idea then of
like machine gun on a robot dog to
prevent school shootings
it's like the political argument like
whenever a school shooting happens a lot
of people like oh the issue that we need
more guns yeah and it's like okay what
does that look like yeah let's do the
extreme of that you know robot dog in
the classroom with a gun just kind of
like you know just making fun of the
whole thing yeah it's funny how annoyed
Americans get it anything to do with
taking guns away because you had a lot
of heat for that video Yeah quite a lot
of heat
yeah I hadn't experienced that before
and I was kind of like and it's scarier
than like the normal heat because all
these people have guns
and it's well some of them because a lot
of them were in America but then I had
some Australians hit me up and be like
you know we've got guns here as well and
I was like well like it's funny to piss
someone off with a gun and their
response is like I'm gonna shoot you
that's all I know I hit a great case for
gun control here yeah any threats or
anything like that or was it yeah a
couple of deaths rights and like like
what like how dare you put a gun on a
dog I'm gonna yeah yeah I'm gonna shoot
you yeah just talking about gun rights
and that kind of thing right yeah right
and you at the same place had a video
kind of just a more kind of political
and yeah
with some of the people on this gun
there's so many guns in America and
we're just kind of trying to work out
like what the justification is and like
a lot of time they they push this thing
where it's like we need guns to protect
ourselves from like a tyrannical
government like you know there'll never
be an evil government if we can defend
ourselves and then we're just kind of
analyzing that saying like I don't know
America's got like crazy police like the
big biggest prison population in the
world but like tyranny's already
happening like what are your guns like
the guns are just a hobby like yeah and
these guys that say they want to use
their guns to protect from the
government they love the police yeah
that was the main point of being like
you're not you love the police the
police came over you'd suck them off
yeah
they're your buddies so it's just
pointing out that they're more of a
hobby we are seeing it and they have
like they're like so proud to show off
like guns from like World War II and
yeah they're like this is a Nazi gun
it's like why why do you have this no
one needs this she's like how do you
have this and it's funny when you get an
obsession with Nazi stuff because he was
like that's a bit weird yeah yeah it's
like why did you have to bring that into
it yeah yeah yeah what I want to know is
how how you went from like guests like
making political videos together to you
kind of like doing I guess making death
machines like how how did that come
about oh so that was kind of like my
whole life I've just kind of he's made
I'm really interested in but yeah it's
not even a joke which is like at school
I was the kind of known as the guy that
would blow things up I remember oh my
God like we would do like horrible
things like I don't know if I should be
saying this but like making letterbox
and then sometimes you'd put a letterbox
bomb in someone's letterbox and then it
wouldn't blow up and then it was just
like it's like is that the movie The
Butterfly Effect yeah yeah yeah that's
the scene and like [__] now there's this
unexploded bomb in this old woman's
letterbox I'm like do I run back and get
it
yeah so it was because in Australia you
can't buy fireworks a bomb so I would
make um I don't know if I should say
actually how to make the Box
what is this thing uh so it's just like
basically it works it's a chemical
reaction that makes a gas in a it's a
pressure bar so instead of just like
it's a gas that expands and expands
inside a enclosed space and then when
there's enough pressure will blow up
right right this sounds [__]
dangerous yeah yeah it's like it's like
when you put like the dry ice in them
it's exactly I think it's exactly that
but just with them what the [__] were
you doing and building these because I
just thought it was fun and allowed
noises and I would muck around with
thermite I remember I um
you can just make it it's just um
yeah yeah but you can just make it and
then um I remember I would tell people
at school and then we came up with the
ideas of melting the school's gate
together so that we couldn't get back
into school or something and then we did
this it didn't work I just set the grass
on fire
do you have any background on like
engineering or science no no not at all
that's probably why I'm so bad at it
that's the angle right people people
watch your channel to see you get hurt
or probably to be inspired that like
this guy that has no idea what he's
doing if he can make it then maybe I can
do something as well you know you sound
almost as insane as uh
I think Nile Reds actually knows me he
knows what he's doing but he's willing
to take more risk like he would talk
about his childhood and it was like yeah
I just love it it sounds very similar to
yours yeah yeah we're just getting like
farming the zinc from the batteries yeah
yeah yeah [__] it's wrong play games
yeah yeah he was telling us one time
yeah I just uh I almost set like a
school on fire or something just because
I was like [__] around I was like how
did you get to that point have you did
you have you have you ever had any bad
almost accidents like
growing up as a kid I feel like yeah I
had a lot of accidents when I was a kid
a lot yeah a lot of always like
cut fingers like [__] up toes from I'm
trying my worst accidents were not from
or I had a pretty good one where I um a
pretty good one with this with a spear
gun where I was like mucking around with
it as a child and I didn't really know
how to use things and I strapped the
speed gun down to a table I don't know
what I was trying to find out but I
thought I didn't know speed guns had
recoil so I put my face really close to
it shot the spear gun and goes back into
my mouth
split open my lip oh my and my thing and
I remember just massive gash
um but no I think that's probably the
worst injury I've had so yeah where did
you grow up this was just in in Sydney
yeah but there's things to do in Sydney
right now
Joe Kitty can you attest to this well I
mean whereabouts in Sydney uh in the in
the suburbs like northern northern
suburbs like northwest suburbs of Sydney
really yeah because I'm from Northern
beaches really yeah so and like I never
heard anyone of your magnitude without
doing anything like that I'm like you're
making bombs yeah yeah we would we did
some pretty [__] up stuff in high
school friends since high school yeah
the thing is like before I met him I
wasn't doing any of this I was playing
World of Warcraft
but let me take you into my world we
used you were the kid that every other
parent was like do not hang out yeah
yeah yeah that was pretty bad
we we had it as well we used to play a
game should we talk about sogging what
the [__] yeah but I yeah I guess so I I
was more auxiliary to that game I never
did
what the [__] it's bad I don't know I
don't know you're a game called sogging
at school where like we had nothing to
do like but we probably did have things
to do but we definitely thought it'd be
fun to go down to like the highway right
we would hide in the bushes and just
throw various objects and objects of
cars and then the police would come and
would run away from the police and this
was like a every week thing
one friend we had one friend that every
time he'd do a poo
it's on like a napkin and then throw it
at cars that's what monkeys do yeah
it's horrible and I still remember the
expression he threw it at a truck and
his truck driver came out he was like
wow we just started chasing I was
screaming like you cheat on our truck or
something
this is the worst thing ever this is
really devolved
I didn't even really like it when we
were doing it I just wanted to have
friends
oh my God this is what you got to do
like wow play discovers how to make
friends yeah
I guess this is how everyone makes
friends in Australia right just uh
yeah but that's kind of the origin of I
did a thing yeah no [__] throwing to
letterbox bombs too so you just wanted
to like yeah just like okay I want to
bring this hobby of mine and just uh
share with the world on YouTube so the
actual the
unlike the actual origin was um so yeah
the experience of that and then Alexa
when I made boy boy and Alexa I think
went to Serbia for a year or six months
and then got into I was meant to be
there for like a very short time going
to like a relationship and just ended up
there forever and I was like I'm not
waiting for this guy yes then I was like
after the boy boy and kind of realizing
a bit of how much potential YouTube had
I was like right I think I can try this
I was like what am I interested in I was
like making things and doing things so I
started that and I think I was at it for
like a year
um with relative success I got I think I
had 25 000 subscribers in the first year
and then the day after the first year
one of the videos caught on right and
then just Channel blow up and then which
which video was that I made a video
called how dangerous is a metal straw
which I tested um just what a metal
straw would do to a human head if you
fell on it in your mouth
um yeah it's pretty bad yeah yeah go
straight through your head yeah yeah
what was the first contraption that you
made on YouTube then
a book that when you open it throws a
throwing knife into your face
now why on Earth would you need that I
just I don't know how I came up with
that idea
just thinking of yeah I mean no one
thinks the idea is that you think of
because no one should think yeah the
tricky is Alex you guys not many people
know this Alex actually does not know
how to read and he's had a vendetta
against books and he's just trying to
like pay back people who actually do
know how to read yeah yeah it was
probably something like that in my head
yeah
no a lot of the ideas I'm just like yeah
out of context I'm like what what does
this look like what is this do I look
like a psychopath thinking of this idea